[Musik]
immer öfter steht die totenglocke in
nico pohl im südosten der ukraine heute
verabschiedet sich die gemeinde von
serie krasniqi der vor ein paar tagen an
der front gefallen ist sein sohn hat
einen tag sonderurlaub bekommen um der
mutter auf dem schweren gang beizustehen
es wird viel getraut den nico pol die
bilder davon hat kriegsfotograf war
richardson eingefangen der die trauer
der menschen hier seit wochen begleitet
wir treffen den australier auf einem
parkplatz am bahnhof von nico pohl unter
dem ständigen geheul des luftalarm
erklärte uns den verlauf der
naheliegenden front
hier liegt nico pol-da ist ein
atomkraftwerk
die russen kontrollieren diese ganze
gegend hier das ist alles ihr gebiet
wie sind siebeneinhalb kilometer
entfernt bis jetzt gab es keine angriffe
in unsere richtung
[Musik]
weil sich das jederzeit ändern kann gibt
es nur ganz wenige momente an denen die
sirenen verstummen
mit
[Musik]
für mich ist es eine alltägliche
situation wenn ich in einem krisengebiet
in den zug steige voller leute die
fliehen mitten unter frauen und kinder
aber die haben keine ahnung wie es für
sie weitergeht was auf sie zukommt was
als nächstes passiert
warum fotografiert tauchte tief ein ins
leben der menschen er erzählt ihre
geschichte erzählt vom horror den sie
erlebt haben damit ihre opfer nicht
umsonst tragen doch manchmal ist die
realität zu brutal die bilder kaum zu
ertragen
was waren ihre pin erlebte hat spuren
hinterlassen auch in seiner seele
meine agentur hat mich angerufen und
gesagt großartige arbeit aber solche
brutalen bilder können wir nicht
verkaufen
auch facebook hat sie von seinem account
verband es sind bilder hingerichteter
von leichen an denen hunde zerren und
soldaten die auf tote gegner urinieren
was macht dieser krieg mit denen die ihn
kämpfen will wochen wissen antworten
sucht dabei den menschen in den kirchen
in der ukrainisch orthodoxen gemeinde
von vater mercury
hier trauern sie fast täglich um einen
der ihren die vielen toten machen den
priester zornig
für gott gibt es keinen tod gott hat das
paradies schon vorbereitet hier haben
die soldaten die hölle erlebt
entschlossen steht der geistliche an der
seite der ukrainischen kämpfer und hält
ständig kontakt zur front wo sie davon
ist er fest überzeugt
stellvertretend für ganz europa kämpfen
am himmel wünschte er sich eine
flugverbotszone
am boden fühlt er sand von
glaubensbrüdern verraten
die russisch orthodoxe kirche wütet wie
ein tumor am körper unserer nation
an vielen orten begrüßen sie die
besatzer mit brot und salz es gab
priester die wollten ihre gemeinde zur
kapitulation überreden und haben ihre
kreuze auf die panzer der russen gemalt
der krieg treibt einen keil in die
jahrhundertealte einheit der orthodoxen
kirche die russischen gemeinden werden
als heimliche helfer moskaus verdächtigt
wir begleiten wollen zu vater nikolaus
dem russisch orthodoxen geistlichen
wir wollen wissen wo steht er in dieser
schwierigen situation
als religiöser mensch setze ich all
meine hoffnung auf gottes gnade die uns
frieden bringen möge aber
natürlich glaube ich an die verteidiger
an die ukrainische armee die eine große
aufgabe hat die heimat zu beschützen
seine herzlichkeit ist beeindruckend
politisch will er sich nicht weiter
äußern auch hinter den dicken mauern
seiner kirche eine eigene agenda steckt
bleibt uns verborgen
waren mit seinen bildern nicht werden
will alle konfliktparteien verstehen und
würde auch die russische seite
im mikro pol sind es kleine geschichten
die das große bild beschreiben frauen
wie sie die ihrer heimat im donders
verlassen die den preis für den krieg
zahlen und auch in nico pohl darauf
warten wie es mit ihnen weitergeht
zu hause war sehr traurig wir hatten 70
tage lang kein wasser und auch das gas
war abgestellt
ist das leben jetzt schwer denn ohne gas
können die bäcker kein brot backen
und so warten viele wie katharina hier
nico pohl auf ein ende des krieges
wieder krieg enden soll natürlich mit
unseren sieg lang lebe die ukraine
es sind die kinder den rohren richards
meinung unter dem krieg am stärksten
leiden weil sie es sind die auf dem
trümmern von zerstörung und flucht ein
leben aufbauen müssen
sie sind die nächste generation
werden sie unversöhnlich oder werden sie
offen seien diplomatische lösung
ich habe keine ahnung ich hoffe es wird
sich eine zukunft für sie finden in der
sie ohne angst leben kann
kurz nach unserer begegnung mit den
kindern das bohren nach hause gefahren
ein paar wochen auszeit mit seinem
kleinen sohn in budapest wo er wohl drei
monate in der ukraine waren viel für ihn
als kriegsfotograf kann er gehen wann er
will die kinder in nico pohl können das
nicht
[Musik]